okay let's go to our caller from the 404
area code to call her from 404 who's
this where are you calling from that is
you who's this okay um hi David my name
is Brittany I've been listening to your
show since I was like 16 when you hadn't
let me call Texas knit on and with it I
really wanted to thank you or I'm really
helping me like shake my political
identity and that's okay you're doing
great so far so far all great things
you're saying no not related policies
and you talk about that all day that's
kind of a very question but so I'm just
putting my minors in Spanish right now
and I'm studying it in school and I
never really heard you speak much
Spanish and I was just really curious as
to what it sounds like from you um I was
wondering if you could say something um
especially my citrus like me to say it
in Spanish okay so mais honesty podría
decir una CK for a second Acadia Thank
You Brittany for calling in and I'm
really happy with program or something
like that I don't know okay Brittany
gracias por su madre esto en Gonzalo
cha-cha Malloy all right I'll be doing
the requests all day folks any other
languages you want just call in and ask
okay okay thanks thanks appreciate the
call okay I'm out of time
on that note a great call to end on
sorry to the 27 people holding I didn't
get to I really do apologize but I'm out
of time I will take calls again that I
promise you